I know I'm probably just being so
dramatic and annoying but this is my
first job like my first 9 to5 job after
college and I'm in person I get on the
train at 7:30 and I don't get home till
like 6:15 earliest and then like I don't
have time to do anything I don't I want
to shower eat my dinner and go to sleep
I don't have time or energy to cook by
dinner either like I don't have energy
to work out like that's out the window
like I'm so upset oh my God she gets
home around 6:15 and all she has time
for is eating and showering I want to
know how long of a shower she's taking
does she have kids that's a long shower
like do you have kids no she has no
concept of time I don't have time to
work out to see boys it's 6:15 what are
you doing